oh thank god she's back it's a little
ironic to name the new Hulk a comic the
immortal Hulk right after he just died
for the up teenth time but it's nice to
have banner back after so long now that
he's getting his second and/or fifth
wind let's take a trip back to the Holtz
heyday when the mainstream still cared
he was fresh off of a failed movie two
years prior and right on track for
another one in three years time this was
the awkward in-between phase where the
Hulk was evolving past being the Time
Traveler's wife's husband but before he
became inferior will Graham I present to
you hulk opposite construction a game
that is almost universally praised by
comic fans and normal people alike what
can I say this games awesome you can do
elbow drops off skyscrapers you can make
a car into boxing gloves buy it what do
you want look at this
you need convincing after seeing this
all right that makes for a rather
unsatisfying review I'll go into more
detail so this game is an indirect
sequel to that last game this time
around we get a story where banners
gamma energy has been stolen by military
folks a bunch of gamma supervillains are
created with his power and yes to steal
inordinate amounts of technology to
build a machine to help get himself
under control with the help of his
friend ponytail man oh no I'm a
hypocrite now we have these two separate
plots building throughout the story the
one where Emily blockers gets infected
with leftover gamma tsunami and mutates
into doomsday I mean abomination what's
happening to you
nothing I suggest you concern yourself
with a problem man unless you want my
headache to become your head it's wrong
proven ultimate destruction also
features the plot more directly related
to banner and his bro Samson where a new
split personality manifests in Bruce's
subconscious called the Joker I mean the
devil hole coincidentally devil Hulk
also believes that marriage can only be
between a man and a woman not a spider
man and a woman
Bruce fears for the continuity and runs
around stealing stuff to build an HTC
vive to allow him to confront his inner
demon and symbolically punch the [ __ ]
out of it this intercuts with sequences
of Blonsky being concerned about his own
and her voice begging him to get after a
bunch of run-ins that end in a stalemate
Bruce eventually outs Blonsky is the
abominable snowman to the US military
who are persistently annoying once they
begin to annoy Blonsky as much as they
annoy banner he gives in to his urges
and lusts for more and finds his dead
wife
wait what okay so his pregnant wife had
a terminal illness that they tried to
cure with gamma radiation and all I did
was turn her into one of my friend
Jeremiah's drawings on his alternate
Twitter account here's a tip for you
kids who want to get into writing games
and movies someday from your old pal
Xavier it's easier to get your audience
emotionally invested in something if
they know it exists for more than 30
seconds why of all these cutscenes of a
meal going nuts over more when his wife
is sick and dying maybe show some
cutscenes early on of him as like a like
a happy family man and his wife gets
sick and he finds her in the hospital
and maybe it was in all those files that
no one reads but like come on this is
basic stuff you want to make a tragic
villain don't half-ass it so bad I mean
it's not like there's anything else
really going on in the story it's just a
big shopping list of fictional
technology getting routinely poached
from RadioShack in the same two
locations over and over Banner is only a
character in cutscenes and he's boring
as Mark Ruffalo's Facebook posts about
fracking so much complaining about frack
anyway you think these two plotlines
would converge and devil Hulk would
somehow be related to abomination but
nope you smash at the devil at about the
90 percent mark of the game and then go
fight abomination who is now hilariously
big causa that's the biggest and most
powerful enemy I've ever faced
what would senpai Superman do I know
I'll lead him to the most highly
populated area on the map and confront
him there
all right blondes and Bea I can't quite
take you in a fight man Oh a man Oh
so how about we settle our differences
with a civilian casualties contest all
started
god damn it it looks like he's winning
over there I can't even do this right
well even after he got all that more ha
he still gets his scaly butt well before
he can blow up the local dam
and there's my god dam then the game
just stops like banner goes well better
luck next time on that cure I guess and
then runs into the woods and there
aren't even credits that's a little
weird and abrupt I guess that was pretty
much what I expected from this game
story it's just a bunch of
underdeveloped ideas loosely slapped
together in order to keep the player
moving there wasn't any kind of
satisfying resolution or interesting
character moments it was just well I
guess it needs a story too why did I
spend so much time talking about this
game's story you may ask well while the
story may just be a lame means to an end
to get from one explosion filled fetch
quest to the next no one else has really
talked about it what do you want from me
to talk about the gameplay that thing
everyone in their mom has raved about
for 13 years the thing we already know
is awesome so talking about it would
just be redundant okay alright think of
some amazing feat of physicality or some
badass fight move you've seen the Hulk
knew once that'll be 10,000 smash points
but you can do it you got your basic
combat with light and strong attacks but
you can grab enemies and bounce on them
like a clever comic related simile the
player can also use cars to make boxing
gloves hit things with a wrecking ball
use a smashed-up bus as a surfboard to
ride through the streets like Red Eddie
and this and this oh and this too
oh and that the combat feels great not
too slow not too fast just the right
amount of powerful well the last game
had you on a pretty tight leash with
linearity this one lets you roam around
between two open world maps that both
get a little tiresome after a while and
make you just wish there was a third one
to liven it up a bit why do these
collectables say they're comic books
when they're just a green coin with a
letter C on it why not make it like like
a comic book
combat wise you can do a lot and you
really feel like a badass for the first
five minutes of the game
then the cold snap of reality sets in
that you're not the strongest one there
is
and your girlfriend's dad will never
like you no matter how hard you try for
all your incredible abilities you're
still kind of a weak-ass loser in the
hordes of military helicopters tanks
robots missile launchers are still a
very real threat I don't often hear
people bring it up but this game is hard
I don't consider myself the best in the
world at video games but I can handle
some challenge here and there this game
however has been one of the most
aggravating I've played and the review
took longer to come out because I wanted
to beat it without changing the
difficulty you're using cheese am I just
bad does anyone else with me on this or
do I just got to get good don't mind me
I'm just a normal walking truck with
huge green feet sticking out the bottom
evening officer nothing to see here
normal truck just do a normal truck
stuff there are times when I even think
the game is being so unclear about
instructions that it adds extra
difficulty here's an example and let me
know if you guys struggled with this too
you got to chase down this helicopter
and steal a reactor from it after having
knocked it out of the sky
it flies way higher than you can jump it
moves way faster than you can traverse
the level and it's protected by this
annoying fighter jet that keeps blasting
you I chase them to this spot where the
cutscene activates and then it flies off
while playing dialogue like
I'm standing there on this roof staring
at my failure thinking this was a game
over a cutscene which they have a few of
in the game then it goes on for a little
longer for whatever reason before the
level actually stops so I try everything
I can
riding the jet to get closer to the
helicopter running past it and trying to
cut it off at the pass or even throwing
objects at it which always hit the walls
because it pulls so many quick turns
around corners then I actually managed
to hit it with something but it does no
damage I'm completely at a loss here
until I look up a playthrough online
this cutscene isn't a game over thing
it's just a cutscene to show that it
stopped for some reason then the camera
angling back at yourself and the horde
of enemies smacking you around or just
like a trick you can run past them and
it's still going even getting slower and
flying lower so you can take it out why
the hell was this cutscene here all it
did was [ __ ] confuse me now boy I
can't wait for all the comments like
this one anyway I think a lot of
missions I struggled with most were
based on the need for more mobility you
can move around pretty easily in this
game but not quite well enough to be put
under strict time limits and chase
sequences that's more spider-man's deal
even with all the upgrades to Hulk's
movement I still found myself cutting it
really close with these races another
thing that got on my nerves was how hard
this game was on my hands in order to
make any headway to anything you got a
hold down buttons and charge up attacks
and jumps holding down buttons so
frequently and for so long both makes it
feel like I'm wearing out the controller
and starting to hurt my thumbs the only
real solution is to play this game while
wearing a pair of Hulk hands the foam
padding is ergonomically designed for
maximum comfort ironically I think some
of the easiest stuff in the game is the
fauces there are many of them and
they're pretty easy to smash you got
your first fight with abomination which
is pretty one-sided this big robot isn't
so bad as long as you'll aim it out and
let your health regenerate a lot and
then you got mercy you know I remember
her from the recent Thunderbolts comics
she's actually a pretty cool character I
don't know why I don't use her for more
stuff and there's my favorite boss in
the game this smaller robot who you can
horribly horribly
abused with a truck
some of the ones I like best in the game
are when you fight an enemy that's ten
times your size I've always thought that
sort of match up in any game was cool I
love fighting kaiju sized enemies as a
small character devil huh look in the
final battle with abomination or both
especially neato cinematic parallels
something I appreciate about this game
is how you can enter a code - plays
abomination and just like that last game
you can play as Jill fix-it Hulk
who's fully voiced and has unique
dialogue during combat in the last game
his dialogue was a little more
situational and felt like it took more
time to add in well here it's just a lot
of generic lines during combat still
pretty cool though especially since they
got the same voice actor who played
fix-it in the animated series I think I
may be in a minority when I say that I
actually kind of enjoyed playing as
Bruce Banner and not as like a goofy
unlock I mean just for real gameplay the
stealth sequences helped to keep it
feeling fresh as opposed to this one
where you're the Hulk 100% of the time
and the constant smashing gets a little
monotonous
[Music]
looking back I see why this game is so
loved by those who played it back in the
day radical entertainment really nailed
it with the gameplay but there are a few
things I think they could have improved
on imagine how much better this game
could have been if it just had a little
bit more engaging in the story more
bosses and more gameplay variety maybe
that just comes down to my personal
preference though repetition loses my
attention really easily and I found
myself starting to wish there was more I
could do while playing this one but
while I think it still had areas to work
on I get why so many people view it
fondly there are a lot of really
ambitious and cool ideas here I'm very
excited to see how they were implemented
and improved upon in prototype wait a
minute you mean these developers didn't
make the 2008 game oh oh no oh god no
[Music]
[Music]